[MUSIC PLAYING]
NICK SHELTA: I'm
Nick Shelta, and I'm
one of the volunteers for the
Christian group at Google.
And what we try to do is have
a monthly speaker series where
our goal is to bring in
speakers who answer questions
that Google can't answer.
And so for this
month's talk, we've
invited Dr. Jeff Schloss
to come and join us.
So I figured I would give
a brief intro to him,
let you know a little
bit more about his work,
and then give it over to him for
the rest of the presentation.
So Dr. Jeffrey Schloss
is a senior scholar
at the BioLogos Foundation
and a distinguished professor
and T.B. Walker chair of biology
at Westmont College, which
he also directs the Center for
Faith Ethics and Life Sciences.
After his undergraduate studies
in biology and philosophy
on a solo programming,
cramming four years
of undergraduate
study into eight--
I'll let him explain that one--
Jeff received his PhD in
ecology evolutionary biology
from Washington University.
And has since been a Danforth
Fellow, a Crosson Fellow
at the University of Notre
Dame, a Plumer Fellow
at St. Anne's College at
Oxford, and a Witherspoon Fellow
in theology and science
at the Princeton
Center of Theological Inquiry.
His current research focuses
on interactivity influence
human social cooperation.
In his own work,
Jeff is especially
interested in helping
the Christian and secular
public appreciate the
emerging findings of science
and is fostering collegial
commerce between scholars
with differing and
no religious beliefs.
Perfectly significant, and for
ways of keeping his own sanity,
he includes his own interests
of surfing and sophomoric humor.
With that said, I will give it
over to Jeff to tell us more.
[APPLAUSE]
DR. JEFF SCHLOSS: It's
great to be with you.
This afternoon,
I want to explore
a centuries old conversation
that has sometimes
been synergistically
celebrative and sometimes
been acrimoniously polarizing.
That's the conversation
between science and religion.
And I want to begin by
telling you a story.
And I hope it's OK to just give
you a little personal story
here.
I'm holding my 3 and
1/2 year old son Gabe
in my arms one evening, and we
walk out the door to our house.
We live in Santa Barbara.
We don't get great
sunsets in Santa Barbara
often because of
the maritime fog,
but this sunset was spectacular.
The sky was
hemispherically ablaze.
I've never really considered
what it's like for a little kid
to notice something
for the first time
about the natural world
that we see all the time.
But this was for the first
time Gabe noticed the sunset.
And I'm holding him in my
arms, and his head turns to me,
his lips are quivering,
and he says, Daddy, look.
God painted the sky.
It was a touching, but kind of
a painful moment, because I had
to say, Gabe, that's stupid.
God had nothing to do with it.
That's just the differential
elastic scattering of light.
No, of course, I
did not say that.
But I tell you this story
to kind of illustrate
two points that we're going
to run with in this lecture.
And the first one was,
well, was it stupid?
When we come up with a
naturalistic explanation
for things, does that
subvert the rational warrant
for thinking that there's
something beyond nature?
And the second
one is, well, Gabe
wasn't doing an
analysis and inference
to the best explanation.
He saw this, and
he just immediately
intuitively
attributed it to God.
So that second question is where
do these intuitions come from?
And over 300 years ago--
It's not working-- the
Scottish philosopher
David Hume says in his
"Natural History, of Religion",
is every inquiry
which regards religion
is of utmost importance,
there are two questions
in particular which challenge
our attention, to wit, that
concerning its
foundation and reason
and that concerning its
origin in human nature.
Now for the last more
than three centuries
most of the discussion has
focused on that first one.
What implications
does science have
for rational warrant,
the foundations
of religious belief in reason?
But recently,
actually just within
the last several
decades, there's
been an explosion of research
into the second question.
What is it in human nature,
if anything, that disposes us
to those kinds of beliefs?
And there have been
scholarly and popular studies
in genetics, neuroscience,
cognitive science,
and evolutionary theory.
I want to concentrate on this
latter question with you.
What is it in human
nature that seems
disposed to these
kinds of beliefs?
But in order to do that,
I need to set the context
in the first question,
foundations in reason.
So there's a popular perception
that somehow the enterprises
of scientific inquiry
and religious faith
are intrinsically opposed.
A few years ago, there was a
theme issue in Time Magazine.
Richard Dawkins and Francis
Collins both weighed in.
Francis Collins, the head
of the Human Genome Project
and now the director of the
National Institutes of Health,
he actually founded by BioLogos,
the organization with which I
have an appointment.
But it's not just
popular controversy.
So here's one of dozens
of quotes I can give you.
This one from John
Dupre, formerly
up the road in the Department
of Philosophy at Stanford.
Dupre says, Darwin undermines
the only remotely plausible
reason for believing in
the existence of God.
There's nothing worthwhile left
of the argument from design
and more controversially
or contentiously.
I want to insist that without
the argument from design,
there's nothing very credible
left of theism generally,
and Christianity in particular.
Now I want to set
aside the question
of whether in fact the
rational warrant for faith
rests on the
argument from design.
There are lots of
other arguments,
the argument from first cause,
and the cosmological argument.
There are other reasons, for
example, first person testimony
or religious experience.
Whether or not all of those are
adequate is another question,
but it's not clear that
faith ever rested entirely
on the argument from design.
But more than that, I want to
look at this second comment,
that Darwin destroys the
argument from design.
And it turns out there's
some merit to that,
but it's not that simple.
There is a tradition of two
types of design attribution.
One type looks at the natural
processes of the world.
And in a sense, it reasons
from their deficiency,
says that natural
processes are not
able to account for
the observations
that we make in nature.
And therefore, there must be
a supernatural intervenor.
But there's another
tradition altogether
that looks not at the
deficiencies of nature,
but the marvelous
endowments of natural law.
So Newton was speaking
in this tradition
when he said, the most beautiful
system of the sun, planets
and comets can only
proceed from the counsel
and dominion of an
intelligent being,
whom I call the Lord God.
Now that might not be
an argument actually.
It's an attribution.
Maybe that's kind of
like Gabe and the sunset.
Maybe that was just a
response, an intuitive response
by Newton.
Since him, however,
a number of arguments
have emerged called
fine tuning arguments.
I'm sure you've
heard of them before.
But looking at fundamental
constants of nature,
like the gravitational
constant, a number of others,
which couldn't have differed
by plus or minus more
than a few percent
in order to have
a life sustaining universe.
Paul Davies, the
physicist at Arizona State
calls this the
Goldilocks enigma.
One of my favorites is this one.
It's not a constant
of a natural law.
It's actually the initial
conditions on which laws work,
the initial mass
density of the universe.
So this is from Ned Wright, UCLA
cosmologist and astrophysicist.
And he posits that the initial
mass density of the universe
was fine tuned to one out of
10 to the 24th or a septillion.
Actually, he's revised this
and added another digit.
And one part greater,
and we would now
be living in the great collapse.
In other words, we
wouldn't be living.
And this notion of fine tuned
to one out of 10 to the 24
is approximately equivalent
to plus or minus one star
not in the night sky that
we see, or in our galaxy,
but in all the galaxies.
And Hebrew scriptures
say, lift up your eyes
and look to the heavens.
Who created all these?
He who brings out our
starry hosts one by one
and calls forth each
of them by name,
because of his great
power and mighty strength,
not one of them is missing.
And the Psalmist
says, he determines
the number of the stars and
calls them each by name.
Now I want to be
really clear here.
I am not suggesting, although
some of my coreligionists do,
that this was a prophecy of
what science would discover
thousands of years before the
sciences were even invented.
I'm not positing that at all.
I'm suggesting that what's
here in the scriptural view
of the world is that the world
is in fact a cosmos and not
a chaos, to use Greek notions.
That the world and
the cosmos we live in,
in fact, is structured
and designed.
Not designed because
the laws require
supernatural
intervention, but designed
because the laws
themselves seem tuned
to what would be necessary
for the rise of life.
And it's not just
the scriptures.
So a number of scientists,
who have no faith in God
by the way, so Fred
Hoyle was an atheist who
said, a common sense
interpretation of the facts
suggests that super intellect
has monkeyed with physics as
well as chemistry and biology.
And up the road here,
Leonard Susskind at Stanford,
co-developer of
string theory, says,
our own universe is
an extraordinary place
that appears to be
fantastically well designed
for our own existence.
This specialness
is not something
that we can attribute to
lucky accidents, which
is far too unlikely.
The apparent coincidences
cry out for an explanation.
Now here, and each
of the major points
I want to make this
afternoon, here, I
need to interject a but.
And it's a big but actually.
This quote that I just
read you from Susskind
is often taken out of context.
Susskind does say that our
universe is a special place.
But this quote is taken from
his book, the subtitle of which,
String Theory and the Illusion
of Intelligent Design.
So he thinks our universe is
a remarkably special place,
but our universe isn't
the only universe,
that there are many,
many, many, many next door
universes greatly
amplifying the probability
that we'd get a universe
that would support life.
There are various permutations
of multiverse theory
or megaverse theory.
And the point I
want to make here
is the question isn't settled.
So the Book of Job actually,
I'm really moved by the fact
that in the Hebrew
scriptures, the Book of Job
contains friends of Job who
are giving arguments for God.
At the end, they get rebuked
by God for defending him with,
quote, unquote,
"proverbs of ashes".
So I don't want to
make that mistake.
These fine tuning arguments
aren't slam dunks.
There's ongoing debate.
But it's also not the
case that somehow Darwin
settled the issue and subverted
all arguments from design.
One of my favorite thinkers,
Pascal, put it this way.
He says, there's enough light
to see that there's something
there worth seeing, but not
enough light to see it clearly
by our natural reason.
He goes on to say, if
there were no obscurity,
man would not see feel his need.
If there were no light, man
would not hope for a cure.
All appearance indicates
neither a total exclusion
nor a manifest
presence of divinity.
We must not see nothing
at all, nor must we
see sufficient to believe
that we possess it.
But we must see enough to
know that we have lost it.
For to know of our loss,
we must see and not see,
and that's precisely the state
in which we naturally are.
The picture here,
and I think this
is the picture of
the Christian faith,
is that you're not an
idiot for believing in God.
It's a plausible hypothesis.
But what might persuade any
of us that there is a god
requires reason is necessary
but not sufficient.
So this strange verse in the
book of Romans, Paul says,
his spirit testifies
with our spirit
that we are God's children.
There's something about
the actual experience
of the presence of
God that's important.
That may be delusional,
but I think I'd rather
be delusional than dishonest.
I don't want to defend God
with proverbs of ashes.
OK.
So now we have
this question then,
where do these
intuitions come from?
And here is the second part,
the origin in human nature.
There's a couple of
ways of looking at this.
Biologists talk about proximate
causes and ultimate causes.
Proximate causes
would be the mechanism
that generates certain features
including mental dispositions.
And ultimate would be, well,
of what adaptive value, if any,
is it?
So there's been a
tremendous explosion
in cognitive science of looking
at fundamental dispositions or
intuitive dispositions toward
certain kinds of beliefs
that we might associate with
God or religious beliefs.
And by the way, one of
the really exciting things
about this field is it's
incredibly ecumenical.
It has Jews and Christians
and Muslims and Jews who
are practicing, but
don't believe in God,
atheists, virulent and benign.
We're all collaborating
with each other.
It's a fun moment right now
of non-acrimonious discussion.
So just for example,
Justin Barrett
is a cognitive science, formerly
at Oxford at the Institute
for Cognition and Culture.
And Jesse Bering is a sweet
spirited but very emphatic
atheist.
Jesse says somewhat tongue in
cheek but not all together,
we've got God by the throat,
and I won't stop until one of us
is dead.
So he's wrestling
with big issues.
And here's some
work that Jesse did.
It's on afterlife
beliefs in children.
So we brings children
into the lab,
and he does a puppet show
with an alligator and a mouse.
And there's a story
about the mouse.
The mouse wants to go home
to be with his mother,
and he's feeling a little
tired, and he's hungry.
And then the alligator
eats the mouse.
And then the children are
sent off for grief counseling.
No, that's not true.
The children are asked a
series of questions about
is there any continuity
between the mouse that was
and the mouse that now is?
And they're told the mouse
is not alive anymore.
The alligator ate it.
So first of all,
biological questions.
Does the mouse
still need to eat?
Still need to go
to the bathroom?
Do the mouse's ears still work?
And the overwhelming
majority of kids
get that at death your
biological functions
don't continue.
Although, kindergartens,
about a quarter of them, still
say yes to these questions.
Second graders,
90% of them don't.
Only one out of 10 says yes.
But then amp it up a little bit.
Psychobiological question, not
does the mouse need to eat,
but does the mouse
have the feeling
of being hungry,
thirsty, or sleepy?
On this one, two thirds of
the kindergartners said yes,
and fully a third of the
second graders say yes.
And you have to get to
fifth or sixth grade
until you truncate
continuity, and about 90%
of the sixth graders said no.
Now here's what's
really interesting.
Lastly, a different
kind of question
altogether involving
desires and feelings.
Does the mouse still
want to go home?
Still loves his mom?
Mouse still believes that his
mom is the nicest grownup?
The overwhelming majority
of kindergartners are in.
Fifth graders, half
of them say yes.
And what surprises
me a little bit,
he brought in college
students for this question.
And about a third of the college
students to the various items
said yes.
And the ones that
said no, there was
a latency in their response.
When asked about the
biological questions,
they said no immediately.
When asked about the
beliefs, feelings,
and desires questions,
even the ones who said no,
there was a latency
in their answer.
So the psychologist
at Yale, Paul Bloom,
an editor of the "Journal of
Behavioral and Brain Sciences",
uses the term natural
born dualists.
Bloom believes that we're
not taught these things,
but there's a
natural disposition
to think of life as enduring
death maybe not altogether
embodied.
Here's one other one.
How about purpose?
The attribution of
purpose to things,
the inclination to
think teleologically.
Deb Kelemen, the
psychologists have
looked at this
behavior in children,
and she asks questions like,
why did the first bird exist?
Well, to make nice music, and
because it makes the world
look nice.
Why did the first monkey exist?
So then we had somebody
to climb trees.
So there can be an
animal in the jungle.
Why did the first monkey exist?
Oh, I already did that.
Why did the first river exist?
So boats can come in the
water, and so that people
can do fishing.
Kelemen calls children
intuitive theists.
But the interesting
thing is she's
followed up on these studies
with adults, including
by the way, doctorally
trained academics, a number
in the natural sciences.
And there's still this
latent disposition
to think teleologically
in adults.
Now what there isn't
there, these features
may a disembodied being
as in Jesse's work,
intuitive purpose,
orientation in Kelemen's work,
these are attributes of God.
But when she calls
children intuitive theists,
the one thing that
is lacking there
that exists in most concepts in
the current world monotheisms
is a sacred dimension.
So these concepts could be
true of leprechauns for that.
But there's something
about a sacred dimension,
and that's something that
hasn't been much studied
in the current cognitive
science of religion literature.
Nevertheless, it's surely true
that we have this disposition
to think in terms of purpose.
Richard Dawkins
himself says, we humans
have purpose on the brain.
The mere fact that it's
possible to frame a question
doesn't make it legitimate
or sensible to do so.
You have no right to assume the
why question deserves an answer
when posed about a
boulder, misfortune,
Mount Everest, or the universe.
Now it's interesting
here, Dawkins
doesn't give a reason
why no one has a right
to ask that question.
He takes it as a given.
And in fact, this
seems to emerge out
of a fundamental and profound
intuition on his part
that there is no purpose.
So in one sense, we have a
battling intuitions here.
Although, it might seem
to you like, well, surely
we can't think of in terms
of a purpose of a mountain.
But as we grow older,
it may be the case
that we are more parsimonious
in what we attribute purpose to,
but also more expansive
and elevating in terms
of how we construe purpose.
So if you want to think in terms
of the purpose of a mountain,
for example, this isn't
a religious statement,
but I'd highly recommend
reading John Muir's
"The Mountains of California"
or his "My First Summer
in the Sierra".
There is a reverential
elevation of these entities
not just in an aesthetic
sense, but in some sense
in terms of a larger geology.
OK.
Whatever the case,
the cognitive sciences
suggest that we have
an innate disposition
to attribute, and not just
to attribute, but to yearn
for purpose.
Augustine says, you have
made us for yourself.
And the heart is restless
til it finds its rest in you.
Now the first question is
a theological statement.
You have made us for yourself.
The second question is a
psychological statement,
that our hearts are restless.
And so why?
Why would that be the case?
And I want to take
a step back and ask
the evolutionary question.
Why would creatures
have these dispositions?
Again, there's an explosion
of evolutionary literature
on cognitive dispositions
toward religious belief.
There has been a fascinating
debate, by the way.
So some argue that we don't
have those dispositions,
that religion is a
cultural pathogen that
infects our brains.
Richard Dawkins says,
religion is a virus
more deadly than
the smallpox virus,
but more difficult to eradicate.
Others say, well, no.
Given the empirical work, there
may be cultural constructs,
but our brain is very
receptive to these.
And in fact, our brain
is disposed to construct
these cultural notions,
but it's not adaptive.
It's a byproduct.
It's an incidental byproduct
of other cognitive mechanisms
that do have adaptive function.
And of course, a third
position in this debate
is it may be a byproduct,
but human culture
has learned how to
use these dispositions
for the flourishing of culture.
Now I want to focus on this
last perspective, in part
because it's one that I've been
working on for the last decade.
But I actually think it would
be accurate to say that there's
emerging consensus in the
cognitive and anthropological
evolutionary
sciences of religion.
So here we go.
I'll set the context
with something
that virtually
everyone agrees on.
So here's an article from the
Philosophical Transactions
of the Royal Society.
Human cooperation exceeds
that of all other species
with regard to the scale
and range of activities.
Human beings cooperate
with individuals
that are not genetically
related and that
are outside the group
boundaries of face
to face historically
remembered interactions.
And we're the only creatures
that do that systematically.
40 years ago in his
seminal "Sociobiology",
E.O. Wilson says,
man has achieved
an extraordinary
degree of cooperation.
Exactly how he alone has been
able to cross to this pinnacle
is the culminating
mystery of all biology.
Well, that was 40 years ago.
And this would be a
talk in and of itself,
but we've come up with
numerous fascinating
and really plausible
explanations for this.
But I'm going to
concentrate on one.
We'll start with this, it's
obvious that in human cultures,
and actually in other
social organisms,
a punishment is important.
So one of the aspects
of human cooperation
that is so difficult to
sustain, because it's
so open to infection, is not
me cooperating with Nick.
If I burn him, he
won't work with me.
But it involves
common goods where
members of a large
community invest in and take
from a pool of shared resources.
And the community can become so
large that you get free riders.
You get people who don't
make their investment,
or you get people who take
more than is their share.
Garrett Hardin called this
the tragedy of the commons.
But punishment can
constrain this.
So here's a common
goods game run
in the lab where
people are given
certain monetary endowment.
You put it in the pool.
It triples, and then you divide
it equally amongst everybody
in the game, including,
by the way, people
who didn't contribute anything.
And as you can see, people
figure out over time
that I'm getting burned
by these defectors,
and then investment in
the common pool goes down.
But admit punishment,
and it goes up.
So punishment is really
effective in stabilizing
cooperation.
But there's some
limitations of this idea.
First of all, punishment costs.
And this particular game,
you had to pay to punish.
But in societies
punishment costs.
You confront somebody, they
might poke you in the nose.
We have to pay for policemen.
It's not free.
And secondly, punishment
is only as good
as the detection
is of defectors.
So it's limited by the
accuracy of the detection.
And then lastly,
punishers are bribable.
They have their
own self-interests.
So what we want, ideally,
to stabilize cooperation
in a society is a moral
overseer who is free,
who is omniscient,
and is unbribable.
Well, you see where
this is going.
That's the posited
role of believing
in supernatural punishment.
So the notions here are the
rise of moralizing deities.
Which by the way, is
not all religions.
So some religions
propose deities
that are either not interested
in the affairs of humans
or are not viewed as
moral beings themselves.
The rise of moral deities
seems to correspond
with the extension of the
size of human interaction
units and culture with
the rise of agriculture.
But this is certainly
not a novel proposal.
I mean, Voltaire, centuries
ago said, if God did not exist,
it would be necessary
to invent him.
Now some people take this as
kind of a sarcastic repudiation
of God, that he was invented.
But that's not what
Voltaire meant.
Now he was a firm critic
of a number of aspects
of the Christian tradition.
But he went on to say,
when all nature cries out
that he does exist,
that there is
a supreme intelligence,
an immense power,
an admirable order,
and everything
teaches us our dependence on it
for reason of social coherence.
Now in the last
few years, there's
just been an eruption of
empirical literature testing
this hypothesis.
And a couple of
books, by the way,
fun books are
Norenzayan's "Bid Gods
How Religion Transformed
Cooperation and Conflict",
and Dom Johnson's
"God is Watching You
How the Fear of God
Makes Us Human".
Dom has a dual PhD
in political science
and evolutionary biology.
His appointment is at Oxford.
And both these guys are
wonderful colleagues.
Both are atheists.
They have absolutely no
religious, pro-religious
agenda, but they're persuaded
that religious belief,
particularly belief
in moralizing gods,
has played a really crucial role
in the origin of human culture.
And in fact, there's
some empirical data.
I'll just share a
couple with you.
This is from some
work that Ara did.
He brought people in.
They played the
dictator game where you
get a certain amount of money.
You can share as little or as
much with an anonymous partner.
And as they were doing that,
he gave them subliminal primes
on the computer.
And when primed with a religious
concept, like spirit or God
or Bible, the offers
basically doubled.
Now he also used secular
police type crimes,
and it had the same effect.
So no one's saying here
necessarily that religion
produces a greater impact.
It's just that there
may be other benefits
as a backup mechanism,
as a mechanism that
doesn't have to be paid for.
But this is in the lab.
Is there any data to suggest
that it actually exerts
cultural or social influence?
And my colleague, Rich Sosis,
a evolutionary anthropologist
at University of Connecticut,
looked at historical records
for 200 religious
and secular communes
in 19th century America.
And he found that for every
year of their life course,
religious communes
were about four times
as likely to survive.
So just the survival of
communes is tremendously
influenced by community
religious identity or lack
thereof.
And there's Rich.
Now there's limitations here.
And the limitations
here are, I mean, here's
a Gary Larson cartoon.
But this idea of a
punishing vengeful God
actually may be efficacious
in constraining defection.
But what it doesn't
seem to be able to do
is motivate supererogatory--
there's a word from
philosophical ethics--
motivate behavior that
goes above and beyond
the minimal expectations.
So this god might punish
you for doing wrong,
for violating what
you're obligated to do.
But we see people all
the time doing what
they are not obligated to do.
So you might think of
something dramatic like living
a life of poverty and celibacy
on behalf of serving the poor,
but it could also be something
just as simple as pulling over
in a snowstorm to
help a stranger
on the side of the road
who's run out of gas.
So one problem is
this doesn't explain
supererogatory behavior.
And another problem is any
society that relies exclusively
on belief in God to do
its moral policing is
vulnerable to
infection by people
who don't share that belief.
So here's the next and
current installment.
It's called costly signaling.
There's a long history
of biological thinking
about signaling in
non-human species.
But the idea here is that one
of the ways that a community can
assure itself that
interacting members in fact
do share in these
beliefs is by commitment
singling mechanisms, costly
behaviors, like for example,
taking one day off every
seven and not working,
or giving 10% of your income
voluntarily, or not eating
a whole range of food which
would otherwise be available.
Rich has gone back,
and he's actually
gone back to his
commune study and looked
at the number of
costly behaviors,
and found that commune longevity
increased with an increasing
number of costly behaviors.
But by the way, only
for religious communes.
It had no effect on
secular communes.
Well, that's part of
the story, but there
are limitations of this, too.
And the limitations
are, number one,
for a costly
signal, whether it's
a peacock's tail or
a religious practice,
for it to be sustainable.
Although, it costs, it has to be
compensated for by the benefit
to the signaler.
If it weren't, it
wouldn't be sustainable.
But now if the cost is
compensated for by the benefit,
then people who
don't believe would
be willing to pay the
cost, because they
get more out of it.
We see this, by the
way, at a lower level
in American politics.
It's almost impossible
to get elected
to major political office
if you're not a churchgoer.
I will forego a comment about
our current political situation
in the US.
But that's one problem.
The other problem is this, the
costly signaling hypothesis
doesn't engage what is
a prominent teaching
in many religious traditions,
which is that what you do,
you shouldn't do publicly.
In the Christian
tradition, for example,
Jesus says, when you
give, don't give publicly
as the hypocrites do blasting
a trumpet before them,
but give in secret.
In fact, don't even
let your left hand
know what your
right hand is doing.
And when you pray, don't pray
publicly as the hypocrites do,
but pray in secret
in your closet.
And your father
who sees in secret,
will reward you in secret.
So there's this stream
of religious exaltation,
in fact, to not do exactly these
public displays of religiosity.
And that brings up the
last and final issue.
It's an issue I have
to say that is under
investigated right now.
But it's the issue of
religious experience.
In order to motivate us toward
supererogatory behaviors, those
that we're not absolutely
obligated to do,
or in order to draw us into
religious practices that
don't enhance our reputation,
it might be the case
that whether it's
delusional or not,
a person who believes
that they experienced
the presence and
intimacy and love of God
might do these things.
So in the New
Testament, Paul says,
we comfort others
with the comfort
we ourselves receive from God.
The last few years,
my lab has been
looking at the relationship
between religious experience
and measures of pro-sociality,
trust and generosity.
I've been doing this
with Hillary Lenfesty,
now at the School
of Human Evolution
and Social Change
at Arizona State,
and Paul Zak from the Center
for Neuroeconomic Studies
at Claremont
Graduate University.
We have folks come into the lab,
take a series of inventories,
just where they self report
on their sense of gratitude
toward God, sense of
intimacy with God, belief
that they're loved by God.
Then we have them actually
do a variety of activities,
sometimes playing a game
or singing folk songs
or worshipping together.
We monitor their oxytocin,
which is a hormone that we know
mediates social relationship.
And then we have them play a
variety of economic transfer
experiments,
standard experiments
in behavioral economics.
And here's what we found.
We found that generosity scales
to a sense of divine gratitude
and intimacy.
We found that in
the activities, it
is enhanced by worship,
in particular highly
experiential or emotional
modes of worship.
And we have worked with people
from the Pentecostal tradition.
And more tentatively, we've
found that generosity scales
to before and after oxytocin,
plasma oxytocin levels.
Although, we're still
analyzing that data.
Interestingly, in
most of these runs,
there have been no in
group, out group difference.
So one of the
prevailing theories
of the social value of
religion is it tremendously
increases in group
commitment at the expense
of out group hostility.
We haven't found that.
And a number of recent
studies actually
have taken a deeper look at
this in group, out group.
It turns out that there's
a large amount of research
that associates
religious commitment
with racial prejudice and
strong out group boundaries.
When we take a deeper
look, if we divide up
the religious
commitment into what's
called extrinsic and
intrinsic religiosity--
extrinsic involves kind of
conformity to extremal rules,
oftentimes for the sake
of personal benefit.
Intrinsic is an internalized
experience and commitment
to religious principles--
it turns out that
intrinsic religiosity
is associated with
a permeability
and relaxation of group areas.
And intrinsic
religiosity is associated
with the rigidification
of group barriers.
OK.
So one last snapshot.
If in fact, we are disposed to
have certain kinds of beliefs,
and if in fact, those beliefs
and the practices associated
with them relate to
the establishment
of social coherence, is
there anything inside us
that would benefit and welcome
from and welcome those beliefs?
So last couple of
decades, there have
been an explosion of literature
on religion and health.
This would be a talk
in and of itself,
but I want to give
you a snapshot.
And I'll close with a suggestion
for an interesting review
if any of you are
interested in it.
But there have been
over 3,000 studies.
The overwhelming
majority of which
have associated various measures
of religious involvement
with cardiac and cancer and all
cause mortality a reduction,
measures of life
satisfaction, various measures
of mental health, depression,
PTSD, even suicide.
And I told you each of my
points would have a but,
and there's a big but here.
The but is many if not
most of these studies,
while the correlations
are there,
were weakly designed, because
they were cross-sectional
rather than longitudinal.
They took particular
groups and scaled them
in terms of their religiosity,
but they didn't follow them.
And the problem
with that is this,
if you have a correlation
between church attendance
and mental health
or physical health,
we don't know whether church
attendance and the involvement
in community and
the meaning making
improves physical
or mental health.
Or is it just the
case that people
with mental or physical ailments
are less likely to get out?
So a lot of these
studies have been flawed.
But in the last couple of years,
there have been some really,
really interesting well
done longitudinal studies.
I'll show you one from the
American Medical Association
Journal of Internal Medicine.
This study took 75,000
nurses and followed them
over 20 years.
They adjusted for age, alcohol,
smoking, educational level
of the individual
and their spouse
if they had one, exercise, diet,
vitamins, hypertension, body
mass index, depression, family
income, and even measures
of social integration,
adjusted for this
at the beginning of the study.
And then just monitored
church attendance
on questionnaires
submitted every four years.
And it turns out that there was,
in those who attended church
once or more a week,
there's a 33% reduction
in all cause mortality
over this 20 year period.
Now why would this be the case?
We can take a look at that
in the questions section
if anybody wants
to discuss that.
But since this study, there
have been a great number
of other concomitant
variable controlled,
long term, longitudinal
studies that
have found similar outcomes for
various measures of physical
and psychological health.
And I'll just
mention that there's
a really wonderful review of
this work a few months ago
in the "Proceedings of the
National Academy of Sciences",
one of the most prestigious
scientific journals there is.
This work was done by
Tyler VanderWeele, who
has joint appointments in the
Department of Epidemiology
and Biostatistics at the
Harvard School of Public Health.
Tyler has been very critical of
a lot of the previous studies.
But in this review
paper, he looked only
at longitudinal
studies that controlled
for concomitant variables.
And the reason I'm
recommending it to you
is because it's not just
on religion and health.
It's on the promotion
of human flourish.
So he looks at various measures
of human flourishing, which
include statements of
emotional happiness,
stability of personal
relationships,
physical health, and some
sense of meaning in one's life.
And he reviews literature in
four areas, family structure,
education, work, and
religious involvement,
and finds that all
of these things
make substantial
causal contributions
to human flourishing.
So to close, none of
this makes religion true.
In fact, it doesn't even make
religion uniformly beneficial.
There are negative
gods beliefs that
have demonstrably toxic effects
on individual and social
flourishing.
But what this does
represent is the questions
represent fascinating areas of
open minded scientific inquiry.
Some of these people, I
mentioned Dom Johnson and Rich
Sosis, I've had the
privilege of collaborating
with for many years.
Dom's an atheist.
Rich is a practicing
Jew, though I don't
know whether he's a theist.
I'm a Christian.
We have fantastic
fun with each other.
And it's a fascinating
area of study
in which I think it represents
right now not conclusions
looking for evidence, but
questions really looking
for answers.
But in addition to
being an area that's
fun for open minded
scientific inquiry,
I think it's one worthy of
existential inquiry as well.
So I'll close with a quote
from Pascal who I began with.
The God of Christians
is not a God
who is simply the author
of the mathematical truth
or the ruler of the elements.
He's not merely a God who
exercises his providence
over the life and
fortunes of men.
The God of Christians is the
God of love and of comfort,
a God who fills the soul
and the heart of those whom
he possesses, a
God who makes them
conscious of their
inward waywardness
in his infinite mercy who unites
himself to their inmost soul,
and who fills it with humility
and joy with confidence
and love, who renders them
incapable of any other end
than himself.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
NICK SHELTA: Yeah.
Thank you for that.
You condensed a
lot into 45 minute.
And lastly, it does give us
15 minutes for questions.
And we can go a
little bit overboard.
So I will pass around the
mic in case anyone has here.
And we do have a Dory online.
I'll actually rotate
between questions on that.
And any of you live
streaming, if you
do want to ask a question,
our Dory is at GofafDory.
First, does anyone have an
opening question from the room?
If not, actually I
had a question myself.
So I remember getting reference
of a study that kind of went
along against the idea
of faith and flourishing.
It was, I believe,
a Denmark study
that was talking about
how people were there,
and I guess it goes back to the
flourishing report, of being
more happy and all that, and
how people outside of the realms
of religion are linked to that.
So do you have any?
DR. JEFF SCHLOSS: Yeah.
I'm glad you asked.
And I told you from the start,
these are complicated issues.
I'm nervous about
oversimplifying.
But let's take a look at that.
OK.
So here, this is an
international survey.
The percentage
saying that religion
is important in their
daily life versus what's
the quality of your life today.
One is from, well
it shouldn't be one.
It should be 10, very best,
one is the worst possible.
And Denmark is at
the top, and it's
one of the least religious
cultures on the planet.
Togo is way down at the bottom,
and it's highly religious.
By the way, this isn't
just true internationally.
So if we look at
emotional well being,
this a Gallup poll with
no particular ax to grind,
and religious
attendance by state.
There's a negative relationship.
And it's also true
with life expectancy,
a negative relationship.
So here's my comment.
First of all, these
studies actually
suffer from the
same weakness that I
said other correlational
studies suffer from.
They're not controlling
for concomitant variables.
So it may in fact be the
case that for various reasons
as the default standard of
living as a society rises,
the religiosity goes down, but
health and happiness goes up.
We call that can
concomitant variability.
The other possible
problem with these studies
is that they
represent what's been
called the ecological fallacy.
Ecological fallacy is
sampling at the wrong scale.
And by the way, my
initial training
was in ecology actually.
And the size of
the sampling unit
made all the
difference in what we'd
find in terms of
correlation with
the environmental variables.
So and I want to thank the
social psychologist David
Meyers for this, if we
look at a different scale,
if we look at the individual
scale here in the US,
we get the exact opposite.
We have increasing happiness
with a just church attendance.
And we get the same relationship
with life expectancy
if we look at the
individual scale.
So with respect
to those studies,
I don't want to dismiss
them too cavalierly,
but they're not
longitudinal, and they
don't control for
concomitant variables,
and they may suffer from
the ecological fallacy.
NICK SHELTA: Well,
I do have a question
that came in out of Dory.
And this is from Grace
from Sydney, Australia.
She said, it's awesome to hear
the ways that science and faith
intersect.
But I also wanted to hear how
people argue that humans just
think they need religion.
We cannot know.
How can we know that we are
wired for the evidence of God's
intelligent design,
or is religion
a result of how we are wired?
DR. JEFF SCHLOSS: Well,
that's the big question.
So we might subdivide
it into two questions.
The first one is an
empirical question.
Does it look like humans--
by the way, I
wouldn't say wired.
Because wired suggests
that it's in our hardware,
and that somehow it's
absolutely innate,
and that no matter what
context we grew up in,
we have these dispositions.
I don't think that's the case.
Biologists describe
phenotypes as gene
by environment interactions.
So one is the
empirical question of,
are we disposed to believe
certain things growing up
in environments that are
typical human, family,
and cultural
environments that are
typical of the natural
history of our species?
And I would say we.
We are disposed to
do those things.
And then the next
question is, OK,
as we construct and imbibe
those kinds of beliefs,
are we not only
disposed to hold them,
but do they make a positive
difference in our life?
I'd say here the
data are complicated,
depends on the nature of
the beliefs, and the way
we embrace them.
But the data seem pretty robust
that certain kinds of beliefs
and behaviors held
in certain ways
contribute to a flourishing
at both individual and social
levels.
Now our friend in
Australia, question
is, OK, so do we have
the beliefs because we're
wired to generate them,
or do we have them
because there is a creator
who wired us to have them?
Well, that's not a question
that's empirically answerable.
Is it?
What we can say is, contrary
to a number of the folks
I cited here is, it doesn't look
like from the empirical data
there's anything that
would subvert that belief.
But the design argument
itself, whether it's fine
tuning of the cosmos
or whether it's fine
tuning of the human
cognitive architecture,
I'm going to go back
to Pascal on this.
There's enough light to see
that there's something there
worth seeing, and not enough
light to see it clearly.
And Pascal says that that's
actually a good thing.
Because if we came
to belief in God
by purely rational
imprints, we'd
believe in God as a proposition.
And he says, if we
have this hunch,
this question that there might
be a God, and we come to God
and ask him, are you there, and
have an interaction with him,
then we have a God who is
a relational loving being.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for the talk.
So I have a question
regarding these studies,
and a little bit think mean
you kind of alluded to it, just
the confounding factors of it.
So you mentioned that, yes,
there were cross sectional
and some were
longitudinal, right,
but 20 years is a long time.
And you normalize
in the beginning,
but if you keep going to
church, perhaps you'll
find a group of people that you
enjoy being with and a husband.
And we know those
factors actually
are affecting your
level of happiness.
So how do you explain that,
not so much genetics, but also
the effect of the
environment and how
that interacts with religion?
DR. JEFF SCHLOSS: So
this was a 20 year study.
I mean, I'm a little
overwhelmed at that
at the scale of this
study, because it's
75,000 people over 20 years.
And they actually went
back every four years
and checked with them and
adjusted for covariates.
So that graph I
showed you at the end
was a graph not of the
actual mortality data,
but a model of
the mortality data
once these other covariates
had been adjusted for.
So we need more
studies like that.
But now the next question
would be, well, why?
What's going on here?
And they did what's
called mediating analysis.
And it looked like that
even after controlling
for covariance, it looks
like social inclusion was
an important factor,
and optimism and hope
was an important factor.
And that differed
between the two groups,
longitudinally studied.
Now one question we
might ask is, OK, well,
if we had something other than
religion that would contribute
to folks' sense of social
inclusion and buoyancy
or optimism, could that
perform a similar function?
And maybe so?
AUDIENCE: Maybe they should
look in Denmark, maybe
like a place like Denmark
where people are--
I mean, I'm not saying or
displaying a little bit,
but Denmark would be a
place where people maybe
have that hope because socially,
the situation is not as dire.
So if you go to Togo,
there's not much there.
Well, I mean, there is stuff,
but you know what I mean.
DR. JEFF SCHLOSS:
Yeah, for sure.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Sometimes it's
the feeling of belonging
can mediate that effect, too.
DR. JEFF SCHLOSS: Yeah.
So yeah, we do need more
international studies
of these things.
Here in the US, there
have been a number
of studies that have targeted
different cultural groups as
well.
So a number of
studies have looked
at just the effects,
one study looked
at just the effects of
religious involvement
on coronary heart disease in
African-Americans, for example.
So a different social group with
different social challenges.
NICK SHELTA: So we did have
one more question in the Dory.
And it was actually about just
definitions of flourishing.
I think this was
in reference back
to your slide of talking about
oxytocin and measuring it.
So I think that what
they were trying to ask
is, what is your definition
of flourishing personally?
And is there a definition
that science can give us
of what is exactly
human flourishing
and where would be the
intersection of the two?
DR. JEFF SCHLOSS: Well, I'll
start with the first one.
I'd be really nervous if we
relied on science to tell us
what human flourishing is.
The sciences do two
things, don't they?
They attempt to rigorously
describe regularities
in the natural world.
And then they attempt to
generate causal explanations
for those regularities.
So in Aristotelian
terms, science
proposes efficient
causes of things.
Aristotle also talked
about final causes.
He talked about the ends for
which things are constructed.
And his notion of nature,
for example, of human nature
or the nature of anything
was highly teleological,
that we had a particular end.
And in his view, and in the view
probably of most of us here,
if there is an end, if
there is a normative telos,
and we miss it, well,
that's called tragedy,
or in physical context,
it's called illness.
But science can't
decide what that end is,
nor, contra Dawkins,
can it decide
whether there is such an end.
So my definition of
flourishing, in my own life,
well, even before
I was a Christian,
I thought that
ultimately flourishing
was to have a matrix of intimate
and loving relationships
with other folks with
whom I could be myself,
they could be
their selves to me,
and for whom we would be
invested in one another.
But, speaking
autobiographically,
and I am so grateful
I've had that in my life,
but that wasn't enough.
And I actually construe
ultimate flourishing
in the Augustinian terms.
You have made us for
yourself, and the heart
is restless til it
finds its rest in you.
That flourishing is loving
embrace of and by our creator
who made us specifically
for that end.
NICK SHELTA: Wow.
Thank you for that.
DR. JEFF SCHLOSS:
Great to be with you.
On that note, join me
in a round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]